corona endlich debatte demonstration wir
haben darüber gesprochen ronald lauder
der erbe des gleichnamigen
amerikanischen
kosmetikkonzerns und der präsident des
jüdischen weltkongresses sagt unter dem
deckmantel vermeintlicher kritik an
kroner maßnahmen ist antisemitismus noch
gesellschaftsfähiger und damit
gefährlicher geworden ja und in der tat
wir erinnern uns wie perverse
verschwörungstheoretiker den juden die
schuld an corona gaben oder die bilder
als impfgegner mit einem judenstern auf
die straße gingen und sich gleich zu
setzen mit den opfern der verfolgung und
vernichtung durch die nazis das waren
wohl die schlimmsten momente während der
demonstration wie müssen überlebende des
holocaust oder ihre angehörigen
solche bilder wahrgenommen haben heute
ist der holocaust-gedenktag der
jahrestag der befreiung der überlebenden
häftlinge des ns vernichtungslagers
auschwitz am 27 januar 1945 durch die
rote armee also heute vor 77 jahren eine
million juden wurden in auschwitz von
den deutschen grausam ermordet auch
sinti und roma homosexuelle und
politische gegner des ns-regimes wer
sich den nazis entgegen stellte der
waren lebensgefahr und als jude war das
schicksal besiegelt schon anfang der
30er jahre begann die jagd auf sie in
deutschland vor diesem hintergrund muss
man ein bild betrachten um den
unglaublichen mut einer frau zu
begreifen als viele juden den deutschen
städten bereits die vorhänge zu zogen
sich vor hass und hakenkreuz versteckten
setzte rahel poster die frau des damals
letzten kieler rabbiners aktiver posner
1931 anzeichen sie stellte einen radikal
leuchter ins fenster und das heer liebe
zuschauer ist ihre bewegende geschichte
ein bild voller dramatik und voller
geschichte es ist nur ein einfacher
messing ständer mit platz für neue kerze
aber für viele juden und jüdinnen ist er
eines der wichtigsten symbole des
überlegen zum kaluga festen 1931
fotografierte rachel posener die frau
des damaligen kieler rabbiners dr adiva
posner den canuck erleuchteter ihrer
familie vor dem hintergrund des
gegenüberliegenden gebäudes das war
bereits mit nazi fahnen geschmückt auf
der rückseite des fotos sie brachte
poster juda verrecke die fahne spricht
juda lebt ewig erwidert dass sich
der grauen des naziregimes zwang den
rabbiner dr akiba große namen mit seiner
frau rachel und den drei kindern nach
israel zu flüchten nur so konnten sie
über bayerische grauenvollen
naziherrschaft überlebt heute steht der
leuchter als dauerleihgabe in der
holocaust gedenkstätte jad vaschem
doch jeder mansbach und seine familie
nach fahrend von rabbi akiba und repos
nachholen ihn jedes jahr für qsc am
chorfest in die kleine wohnung nahe
jerusalem wo er hinter einer mitteilung
städten scheibe brennt und zeigen so vor
allem eines die weniger lebende
zeitzeugen es gibt desto wichtiger
werden relikte um das vergessen des
grauens zu verhindern
und wir sind jetzt live mit ruth uhr
verbunden sie ist die direktorin des
deutschen freundeskreises jad vaschem
der gedenkstätte in jerusalem für die
von den nazis ermordeten juden frau uhr
vielleicht mögen sie einmal kurz
erklären wie bedeutsam dieser
kerzenständer ist
ja guten tag das ist bedeutsam weil das
hat die show aber lähmt das kam wie
gesagt 1933 nach palästina und ist
heutzutage in jad vaschem leider
natürlich viele leute in kiel wussten
dass bisher nicht dass ein teil ihrer
stadtgeschichte in jad vaschem in
jerusalem ist sie haben ja auch
nachfahren der familie posner besuch in
israel wir haben die gerade auch schon
in unserem kleinen beitrag gesehen wie
emotional war das
extrem emotional ja ich habe die
besucher zum letzten tag von hannover
genau 90 jahre nacht des bild entstehen
wurde und wir haben zusammen die letzte
kerzen von kaluga zusammen gezündet und
das war extrem emotional und die waren
auch sehr berührt dass wir sozusagen
figurativ diese hanno kia zurück nach
kiel bringen wollen
hier gibt es jetzt auch eine große
aktion gerade 60.000 aufkleber des
amokläufers sind verteilt worden die
leute sollen sich die in die fenster
kleben wie ist die resonanz
unglaublich und nicht nur in kiel
eigentlich überall hier ist es dicke das
ist ganz einfach zu kleben das macht man
so und tut ab die fans fensterscheibe
ich denke das ist eine ganz einfache
partizipativer demokratische art zu
erinnern und das bringt wie gesagt eine
stadtgeschichte zurück an die leute aber
was uns besonders beeindruckt ist es
geht viel viel über kiel hinaus selbst
der bundespräsident hat hat auch der
sticker benutzt und und viel viel andere
mal in deutschland also ich denke diese
aktion licht zeigen wenn das hat eine
unglaubliche resonanz deutschlandweit
nun ist wir haben es gesagt heute der
holocaust gedenktag vor auch hier in
berlin findet in dieser minute einer
kranzniederlegung
am holocaust-mahnmal statt der
bundeskanzler olaf scholz wird da sein
der bundespräsident
steinmeier wird da sein auch der
präsident der knesset des israelischen
parlaments mit levi wird da sein wir
erinnern uns an diesem tag aber an den
restlichen tagen des jahres erinnern wir
uns eigentlich nicht ist das ein
lippenbekenntnis nur an so einem tag
da nicht wir sind so beschäftigt mit
unsere tägliche leben ich finde das ist
wichtig ist es ist ein tag gibt
natürlich müssen wir uns bemühen die
leute zu verbinden mit dieser geschichte
natürlich das ist nicht eine thema daran
man denken will man hat andere probleme
heutzutage aber
das ist so wichtig für die gesellschaft
her um für die gesunde gesellschaft das
es gibt dass das die leute wissen was
das bedeutet für sich selbst nicht nur
als ein teil die geschichte frau uhr ein
problem ist natürlich auch dass nur noch
sehr wenige zeitzeuge von damals leben
77 jahre ist das ganze jetzt her wie
wichtig sind denn so im relikte um das
vergessen tatsächlich dann auch zu
verhindern
ganz genau also wir sehen dass die dass
die leute die zeit folgen sterben aus
natürlich durch die direkte erzählung
von zeitzeugen hat man eine direkte
emotionale verbindung emotionale
verbindung ist sehr sehr wichtig deshalb
versuchen dass wir das mit andere
methode zu machen mit aufnahmen von
überlebende oder natürlich mit relikte
und etwas hat die große sammlung in der
welt von artefakten und dokumenten die
das vorgeschichte erzählen und deshalb
versuchen wir so viel wie möglich leute
in deutschland mit ihre eigene
geschichte zu verbinden die in jad
vaschem setzt
rot uhr die vorsitzende des deutschen
freundeskreises
etwas schon vielen dank für das gespräch